hello so we'll see how this talk goes
because I don't know how the rabbit-hole
for like particle physics goes pretty
deep yeah fantastic
I saw the the quantum generalize well so
I was like if it weren't right before I
would have been in there watching along
yeah so the first part of this
presentation is going to be a very brief
introduction to the standard model
I'm just show you guys the particles and
then to be on time we have left because
that's freaking awesome by the way we
can actually get into the actual data
analysis like what what cuts did you
make on data in order to calculate the
mass of like the Z boson hopefully we
have more questions I'm gonna try to
leave a lot of question time because
that way I'll know what's actually
valuable to you guys as opposed to hey
here's all the information I've ever
collected about this stuff okay
fantastic thank you guys all for being
here boy
so how many people have seen this before
yeah you have a lot of energy that's
good it's good okay so most of matter is
made up of these particles and electrons
here you have your force mediators and
here's the Higgs boson I don't have time
today to describe why we need the Higgs
boson these fields but after this talk
we can talk about that too you don't
have to memorize any this stuff I will
say the new one is the only particle
that you probably didn't didn't use
electrochemistry class or so like that
they will be discussed today up and down
quarks make up protons and neutrons and
you guys know about electrons okay
mm-hmm
I'll see if it's worse
yeah videos are awesome the
visualization is really help
okay I shall so probably talk a couple
things in order to find these very very
small particles we smash our ten to the
tenth protons during our ninety-nine
percent speed of light and you'd see
particles that you haven't existed since
like the beginning of the universe does
a how many people here have heard of the
LHC Large Hadron Collider it's nice nice
well I'm amongst nerds I feel like I'm
most friends how many people here know
what a hadron is fair enough fair enough
so hey drones were made of the quark
material but have you hear something
like did I talk about mess Hans no not
not today so there's a couple different
experiments that are going on
sterling the LHC and the one that I
actually did did an analysis with was
from Atlas so this explains Alice better
than I could
[Music]
[Music]
in a 27 kilometer underground ring near
Geneva protons are accelerated to near
the speed of light and collided here at
the CERN laboratory scientists can
recreate the conditions of the universe
immediately after the Big Bang the huge
Atlas detector which studies these
collisions took several years to
assemble but through animation we can
watch it in a few minutes throughout
much of the Atlas detector there is an
intense magnetic field this is produced
by passing current through about 80
kilometres of superconducting cables
housed within a large toroidal structure
this enables Atlas to maintain one of
the world's largest volumes of intense
magnetic field it is important to
measure the energies of particles which
pass through the detector this is done
by a device known as a calorimeter Atlas
has several types which are arranged as
barrels placed in both the center and at
the ends of the detector the 3,000 ton
tile calorimeter is composed of steel
and a special material which lights up
when particles pass through the tile
calorimeter surrounds a second
calorimeter
which consists of lead bathed and liquid
argon which is cooled to minus 180
degrees Celsius this is known as the
electromagnetic calorimeter outside of
the calorimeter there is a further
component which measures the trajectory
of charged particles called muons that
reach the outermost layers the surface
area of this component the muon detector
is around the size of several football
fields
close to the heart of the detector
several components are designed to
measure the trajectories of passing
charged particles with an accuracy of
close to one hundredth of a millimeter
one component known as the transition
radiation tracker consists of several
hundred thousand tubes filled with gas
and gold wires inside the transition
radiation tracker are several detectors
built out of silicon and divided into
millions of thin strips and tiny pixels
[Music]
the Atlas detector is designed to
measure as many particles as possible
and further detector modules are placed
at the ends to measure particles
produced at small angles to the proton
beams toroidal magnets are placed at
both ends of the detector to produce the
intense magnetic fields that Atlas needs
[Music]
the detective construction is finished
with the addition of further layers of
detectors for measuring particles which
reach the edges of Atlas
[Music]
[Music]
now let's look inside the detector here
we can see in more detail the pieces of
individual components
[Music]
the tile calorimeter the electromagnetic
calorimeter the transition radiation
tracker and the silicon devices in
reality a scientist would not be allowed
to walk through the open detector but in
this case it illustrates the sheer scale
of the Atlas detector
now we can finally witness the Atlas
detector measuring the particles from
the colliding protons a typical
collision produces many hundreds of
particles and each component of the
Atlas detector is necessary to build a
full picture of the collision
if you want to know how it all works
don't miss episode 2 the particles
strike back it was pretty good model of
it this is what it looks like in real
life when it's of course not in use
so this thing generates a ridiculous
amount of information every year
unlike the petabyte level the next short
video you will see it basically
describes how they collect the data and
how they kind of ship that around the
world most of stuff that I interacted
with was not experimental data it was
Monte Carlo stuff so you can check like
hey this is what my theory says we
should get what what did the experiment
say when the Large Hadron Collider was
broken down for a number of years it
took a lot of like PhD so writing papers
like extra years longer because it was
broken that kind of sucks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes sell it like a physicist didn't make
this video that was obviously made by
someone who's white does that for a
living is impressive all right so when
you're looking for a particle that you
don't know if it exists
you kind of get theory about it back and
I want to say 1964 Higgs in like four or
five of the guys put forward their
papers and took 48 years before it
actually it tested and confirmed that
the particle existed it's it's a good
run for funding stuff so what particles
can we see we can see electrons oh I say
see like we can detect electrons protons
and nuance and so what is a mu 1 mu 1 is
like an electron but it's 200 times
roughly 200 times heavier it doesn't
live very long but if you get them to go
faster because of special relativity it
thinks that it's loading the same amount
of time so you get to go a distance
that's longer then you can predict
without special relativity that's kind
of cool when a Z boson decays it to of
its decay modes are into mu on auntie
melon pears and so if you see a if you
see one particle going off in like in
this direction and you see another
particle going off in exactly the
opposite direction when this starts
happening what thousands of times
eventually you can't ignore it there
must be something there one analogy that
was used is like if there were an you
know an alien race that came to earth
and they couldn't see patterns of black
and white if they saw a soccer match I
first be like what are they doing and
they might think that people just run
around in the field but eventually they
might conclude that there's some there's
some ball some some particle
that that they just simply cannot see
but still exists that's how things like
the Z boson and all the other particles
of the center model that we can't see
directly that's how we know they're
there because we've done this millions
of times now why do we care about the Z
boson we care about the Z boson because
the Higgs boson is predicted to decay
into a pair of Z bosons so if we can see
enough pairs of Z bosons well then
something some particle is there perhaps
it sags perhaps it's not that's now
we're pretty confident it is big a
particle but you have to run it through
a bunch of tests before you say ok this
is the Higgs boson that was predicted by
those series
[Music]
so you generate money I call it data are
you in my case you get it from CERN from
one of those two two centers and at
first like you have a you have a ton
this is after acceptors some of my
selection cuts a lot of them have like
no energy or are like null events and so
usually this peak looks like down here
and then you have like a big bucket it's
like yeah over here you cut those out
because doesn't make your graph look
pretty and then you want you want higher
energy your David looks better when you
go for higher energy particles in order
to say how you calculate the invariant
mass or what does the invariant mass I
would have to write out yes so you guys
know like e equals mc-squared for that
oh let's knock the complete design
complete story it's actually e squared
equals MC squared that quantity squared
plus the quantity P C squared
when you subtract the momentum side
let's see if you have Y squared you
subtract that P squared side and you
take a square root of that to find me
very mass and you say hey does my
distribution match what the physical
theory tells us and if your theory if
your xxx doesn't match experiment
usually you got to go with the
experiment so anyway
there's five minutes left so I'd rather
take questions because I don't know what
you guys know what you don't know and
that's very stressful for me because
then I don't know what's valuable and
what's not so let's just go to that and
if you didn't clap you're right I thank
you so much that was really interesting
I guess this is more along the line of
kind of the selection of what you're
looking at what sorts of algorithms are
you using when you simulate the standard
model pieces that you want are you like
doing a Bayesian method of within a
tolerance or just kind of simulating
things and then using machine learning
to kind of sift through everything
yeah I'll be honest how the Monte Carlo
did itself is generated I don't know
much about that kind of gets past me and
then we were using a lot of scientific
data analysis framework called root
which has a strange name because like
root means thing other things too but uh
anyway we use root and C++ a lot
recently though pythons of course blown
up so a lot more of the analysis is
happening with that but roots is that
that package when you talk more about
that I can share links that way
did I accurately answer your question or
answer your question just some extent to
the answers I don't know yeah fair fair
any more questions
you'd mention that you cut out some of
the data to make yeah but the percentage
of the total data set was cut out gosh
most of it won't let me so in case you
guys aren't actually gonna be like this
guy doesn't know [ __ ] excuse my language
I appended an old an old talk to back
this so let's see Shh this will this is
what the deal looks like without cuts
yeah well let's say it says uncut but
it's not fully uncut because some did it
is like a physical level back at CERN
and I don't believe the data that would
have been generated
they wouldn't they wouldn't pass to us
anything if there's only one in 10,000
of those original like events that come
through they wouldn't I don't know how I
don't know how to say strictly so I'm
gonna stop that but if you see this this
dead first bucket where most most of the
events or many many of the events are
events we don't care about I just don't
know whether many of these are at done
in that physical level when they choose
one out of 10,000 or at the software
level where it's one event out of every
100 does that make sense so this this
bucket you that's the first thing you
cut out the let's see here now these are
different these are different cuts you
make on your data
this is momentum so oh there yeah I just
at the end by the way you have 74% I
guess yeah I forgot so yeah you have
about 70 74 percent from from this
particular run but I don't know if
that's aI don't know if that's just this
particular case or if that's the average
that make sense
cats yeah we got one over here hi thanks
so much um you were mentioning something
about working with Markov models and
then in the intro of your talk the cup
models if you could speak a little bit
about that sure uh
I actually I didn't really work with
Mike Markov processes or anything like
that it was Monte Carlo generated data
sorry not really not really it's not I
wish I wish I could but yeah I'd yeah
more questions
yeah
thank you um back on that graph where
you had cut out a bunch of the data uh
sorry
yeah no problem so yeah this one and you
had the zoom didn't one where you could
see the peak more clearly um you don't
need to go to that okay so I might have
missed this you might have explained it
but and I might have missed it but um
what did you interpret from this like
the spike around this this peak at 91 so
of course this is this is not a
continuous distribution there are small
buckets right and many many of the
events fell on this zero or I don't know
if the the classify non-event says
negative one I don't know if it's like a
special categorization but I'm trying to
I guess I'm trying to ask like did this
prove something that you were setting
out to prove and I missed what it was
like showing you yeah
so on when you're trying to match the
experimental data with what your theory
says you want to have your software
ready for what does out there you say
what what does our what does that like
kind of curve look like from the
theoretical perspective because if you
need to generate like this line and then
you have data that like overlap set if I
end up getting an experimental curve
that is like over here right
and it'll been this this lines wrong and
a lot of the work at the time so this is
back in B 2010 a lot of the work at that
time was was more on the theory side and
not me experimental side because it
wasn't fully up and running until years
later okay yeah I I in terms very like
very low energy events okay thanks
one final question
[Music]
once
twice all right we're good yes
[Applause]